mike fires making his third start
looking for his first victory of 2020.
just getting started top of the first no
score and fires
deals is swung on driven to left field
but it's playable canner right there
about two steps toward the line to make
the catch so the rangers go down one two
three with the a's coming up in the
bottom half
and of course it is mike miner that is
getting the start this afternoon for the
rangers
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
lorianno
two away a good looking change up there
that jeff mathis called and no doubt for
mike miner he's pretty happy to see
his catcher out there this afternoon
bought over the second no score
and olson what a night for matt last
night two home runs to give him three
olsen to right field hit well
and that baby's gone pretty sure
somebody's heating up
101 miles off the off the bat
just a little hanger here nixon in the
middle
and maddie mustache delivers and the a's
take a one-nothing lead
so that brings up chris with a k davis
making his first appearance of the
series
and he swings first pitch and ropes in a
short diving snag by elvis
diving towards the outfield grass to his
right
and he takes a base hit away from davis
to end the inning
here's shinsuchu trying to bun his way
on his first time up
and he got him swinging and that's a
nice inning for mike fires
and with nobody out days one rangers
nothing in the bottom of the fourth mark
canna
walks into the box from the right side
he's over one today a's looking to build
on their one-nothing lead that's a base
hit center field
lorianna running all the way he's going
to come in and score easily
marcanna comes through and the a's lead
to nothing it's a backdoor hanging
breaking ball
right back up the middle was aboard
chapman stopped at second base no place
to go but home
he's got runners everywhere chapman
cannon pinder third to first
that's a base hit left field chapman's
going to score they're going to wave
home arcana he's gonna score
tinder hustling the third and he makes
it safely
huge hit for the ace and it comes from
chris davis
a two-run single for chris davis and
that doubles the oakland lead to
four-nothing
three-run inning and a four-nothing lead
for oakland
still only one out for piscotty and
stevens sends one in the air softly to
the center field
solak is there he'll make the catch
pinder tagging
and he'll score uncontested so the
hustle by
chad going first to third on the base
set by davis draws in a run
a sac fly and a six star bi for biscotti
make it five
nothing oakland a one out count photo
izzy the pitch
he swings loops it in the air to center
field loriano coming on dives
he can't get it it rolls past him and
goes to the wall is he racing around the
bases hits the bag at second as loriano
picks it up on the track
izzy gets to third standing up and stops
there
it's a one out triple for isaiah connor
philippa
anderson tijeda saw one pitches first
time sees one pitch this time and hits
it through the right side to base it
into right field
isaiah kinder full of the scores and
anderson to haiti with his first career
major league hit
and first career major league rbi to get
the rangers on the board here in the top
of the fifth
not intimidated by big league pitching
and he's in there stolen base for tajita
all right first hit first rbi first
stolen base
let's go ahead and knock out that first
run scored and check off all those boxes
four run lead in the bottom of the fifth
inning marcus simeon
2-2 from minor got him swinging and
that's number
one thousand in miners career two gone
in the inning
mike miner congratulations on the one
thousand first recount two ounce nobody
on
this ball hit well by frazier carrying
deep out to left it's gone
a home run frazier with his second home
run of the year
and he makes it a 5-2 ball game here's
anderson to hate it
two played appearances in his big league
career he's seen two pitches
ooh hits his ball well deep out to right
to hannah with a two run shot and what a
coming out party for the rookie
it's five to four and this young man has
made
an immediate impression davis in a
scoring position and now
franklin barretto is going to pitch run
for kd as oakland
looks to build on their 5-4 lead here in
the seventh here's murph
up the middle under the glove of anders
a base hit and the a's will get an
insurance run murphy comes through
barretto scores
and it's six to four there's willie
calhoun
he is have the shift pitch line to
second
and this should be a game ending double
play and it is
chu gets caught off on the line drive
and that's how the ball game ends
and when you're hot that's what happens
so the athletics finish off the
three-game sweep